let's turn to our friend uh whose
twitter uh
um whose twitter breakdowns are just
phenomenal the baldy breakdowns just
need to be seen brian baldwin are back
here on the rich housing show how you
been baldi
rich uh i'm i'm good i'm good i hope
that you and
the wife and the kids are all you know
good and protected and all that kind of
stuff
um we're hanging out in this co-good
world
that we all have to uh sort of uh guard
ourselves against
um living in a film room is a naturally
safe distant place
people don't come in there rich it's me
and uh
32 nfl teams and a bunch of players and
i just kind of live in my little fantasy
i feel
fortunate i can do all of that so uh and
and brian as i mentioned earlier i mean
just your your manner of speaking and
your folksy way of breaking it down in
an
entertaining but also informative way
really makes it particularly special and
i i can't call enough attention to it
and richard sherman has tweeted about it
you've seen other players
tweeting about it who who is who is the
tape hero who has been the
the guy you put the tape on and you know
it's gonna be phenomenal but uh
consistently uh better than you even
knew it would be who's been that guy all
year long for 2020
for you bro well i mean rich as a
long-suffering jet fan that you are
yes uh you cannot turn a jet tape on
and not look at highway 77 over there
left tackle look at you and makai
beckton
um he literally i mean i joke around it
you you call it folks i mean i
i i try to have fun but i can't imagine
mackay beckton putting up
holiday ornaments or decorations i mean
if he touched
one of my christmas bulbs that are on my
tree right now he would smash i mean
everything he hits gets smashed i have
to watch macbeth vectors
no kidding so obviously no you're not
just trying to tailor it to an audience
here brian i mean like that's really the
guy that
that's been so consistently dominant on
tape this year has been the left tackle
of an 0-13 team
but he's that good well i mean you know
it's easy to go to aaron rodgers and go
how does he get this ball to devonta
adam sure without ever looking at him
and it's it's just it's an audible it's
just check
but there's no communication isn't a
lookout and the ball comes out in the
first play last week
and he hits devonta adams for five yards
or
patrick mahomes uh there's just no
answer to anything that he does
everybody has tried i mean brian flores
tried his best he
intercepted three passes last week and
you could put a blindfold on patrick
mahomes he's going to find travis kelsey
in the middle of the field
i i mean the beautiful thing about our
league
in the nfl rich is there is never
enough great athleticism
or skill it never runs out ever
and so you could go around and i pointed
out the jets because
they're the worst team in the league
right wise but there was a player on
that team that
you would want to watch and you would
pay to watch
brian baldinger here on the rich eisen
show last night justin herbert was
exactly that
what are you seeing out of this kid that
that um
that adds to the or backs up the
superlatives that people keep throwing
out that the chargers have a keeper
here in justin herbert you remember
robert redford in the natural he was roy
hopps
to me justin herbert is roy hobbs
like nobody could have predicted coming
out of oregon
and what they called a system offense
that he could make everything look so
easy and natural including the 53-yard
strike in overtime to jaylee guyton
uh you know set up the you know the
quarterback sneak to win the game
i mean he i was there at sophie stadium
rich in week two
when broad taylor bless his heart goes
into the locker room before the kickoff
and nobody knows
what's going on and next thing you know
he's thrown in there against the kansas
city chiefs and he takes the ball right
down the field
and scores against the chiefs and he
knew five minutes before the kick that
he was going to start
he's been the natural all year long and
everything from
his ability to just throw a football
like it's the easiest thing in the world
to getting out of harm's way
to put the ball in the right location
you know to us alluding the rush
against some of the great athletes that
chase him i mean he's been like that all
season
so um your defensive rookie of the year
would be who then
if this is is he your offensive rookie
of the year or justin jefferson does
actually give him a uh
a run for his money and then and then
and then we can transition to this
route adams is but he's doing it in a 21
year old body
now he has two plans rich we give play
planning open and then a plan after the
catch
to i mean nobody's in that rookie class
of 35 receivers that were drafted
plays the game like justin jefferson um
he's probably already the best offensive
player on that team uh and it's a bright
future
but i would say defensively right now i
think
the washington football team are playing
lights out defense
and you could put chase young in a
tuxedo
and he would look james bond smooth and
then
he would he but but as smooth as he is
he's just as violent
his movement is just rare that's all
brian baldinger here
uh on the rich eisen show who's the who
do you think is uh
the the best team in the nfc you know
you've got drew brees coming back
for the saints against the chiefs so
that's gonna happen
uh you've got rogers you just mentioned
how terrific
um he has looked on film and we've seen
it
in real life motion as well you've got
the rams
that have that grown ass man 99 right in
the middle
of a defense that has number 20 on the
back end you've got
the seahawks looking the way that they
look um
in the last month you've got also the
bucks at some point we assume
are gonna have a run in them um
who do you think is the best team in the
nfc and you can even throw the
washington football team in this mix
the way that they've been playing the
last watching football team might be the
best defense
in the nfl before the season's out um
they just physically just annihilate
teams but
uh i i can be hard to go against green
bay right now because i think what matt
lafleur
and aaron rodgers have now figured out
if they have a plan
for whatever reason it doesn't matter
what your defense is
or who's the stars on the other side
there's a plan
and i don't know that anybody can
execute playing better than aaron
rodgers right now so
i mean they're going to put blood points
we know defensively rich that
you know teams can you know they can run
the ball down their throats at times the
way the 49ers did last year
the way the the bucks did this year um
so there's there's a weakness there that
probably won't go away
but they have they can put a 35 or 40
spot up on just about anybody right now
the way aaron rodgers playing the ball
doesn't
wow for crying out loud it doesn't
matter where he throws it
they're in sync matt lafleur and aaron
rodgers and they're going to be tough to
beat
and so then the afc team that has the
best opportunity to
prevent the what we're assuming is the
inevitable of the chiefs returning to
the super bowl which
which team is that for you uh brian what
do you got for me there well i think
that
i think teams that can really run the
ball well
like cleveland could be a tough matchup
for kansas city because if you
can you know look the old
uh you know if you can play keep away
from patrick mahomes and not
allow them to have the ball very often
or limit the possessions to six or seven
in the game
and if you could take one away and force
a field goal whatever i mean you might
be able to keep the score down and
cleveland the way they can run it
could be a problem for him uh buffalo is
capable of getting
a shootout with just about anybody the
way that quarterback is playing the wage
to five digs is playing
where they could put up a lot of points
and defensively
they do a lot they're very creative what
they do defensively they're very good at
certain positions
so i would say buffalo with cleveland
could be two
possible roadblocks to the chief's
returning
uh to the super bowl and i guess to to
wrap it up you want to talk
because you mentioned an afc east player
that's fun to watch how much fun is josh
allen
how much fun is it watching him brian
well part of the fun
is i mean honestly nothing ruffles him
at all
ever right and nobody and part of the
fun is nobody could have predicted this
coming out of wyoming nobody
that he could be a 70 completion
quarterback amazing
that all the the crazy wacky plays that
he tried to make as a rookie
would just disappear um you know and
when he gets into a rhythm
like he did a couple of money nights ago
there's nothing that can really stop him
um except just throwing the ball away to
avoid a rush
but he is he's and his arm is a cannon
i mean 80 yards is not out of question
for him to put the ball in the air
i've seen it so he is he is exactly what
every team is looking for to find
the franchise quarterback and then build
around him the way bran
uh branham dean and you know sean
mcdermott have done
and do it the right way i mean they're
they're the poster child for how to
build a franchise right now
and then you know uh a phenomenal week
15 game
um it's the lincoln riley bowl uh with
kyler murray hosting the
quarterback that succeeded him in
oklahoma it's jalen hurts his first road
start what did you see on film about
how jalen has maybe corrected some flaws
covered flaws in this offense that
unfortunately wentz was only
accentuating what did you see out of
hertz that makes you think this could be
something possible for the eagles to
keep
repeating well he has uncanny poise rich
uh the touchdown throwed al shawn
jeffrey i mean he got hit right in the
kisser
by quan alexander they flagged him for
it the ball went exactly where he wanted
to go so he made a big time throw to get
up
get him up seven nothing they spied him
all game long
with a variety of players it didn't do
any good he just he's one of those guys
that
i don't know how fast he is but he's
he's as fast as he needs to be
nice um and so just the way kyler is so
that's
that and then you know he's a great
runner he was coming out of channel view
high school outside of houston and he
was
at alabama for his first two seasons
there
and when he had to at oklahoma he was
he's a good runner
he has a good feel for the lanes are
um you know he knows how to protect
himself any kid out of texas knows how
to slide and you learn how to slide when
you're four
in texas he knows how to slide protect
himself and
and then you know he it wasn't a very
complicated game plan but he executed
and so he put the ball where miles
sanders and dale rager could do
something with it after the catch and
for the first time
all year you know and philadelphia eagle
quarterback wasn't sacked in the game
and that's a testament to him getting
the ball out of his hands and
not holding it and not you know coming
unglued as soon as somebody showed up in
his face
and he was really good at it and you're
great at breaking it down man
uh brian i i really do enjoy uh watching
what you do and it's bite size
two and a half minutes minute and a half
year minute 45. congrats on getting the
uh
you know more uh every year attention on
that and let's do this more often
brian happy new year to you and yours
uh i appreciate that rich thanks very
much for having me and uh
yeah happy holidays to you and thanks
all of you as well mitch appreciate it
you take care of yourself brian baldwin
at baldy nfl
please follow him it's it's really
dynamite you will not uh
you will not ruin it hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here